The answer is that you're on the moon.
Now there are many ways you can solve this question, but the one that I think is the most fun
and probably the most useful is figuring out how range, the distance you can throw an object,
scales with the acceleration on the planet. What do I mean by that?
I mean figuring out its proportionality.
Is the range proportional to the acceleration in the planet? Is it proportional to the square?
Is it proportional to something else? Let's see if we can find that out.
So this has become a question of, "How does range scale with acceleration?"
The reason why we're looking at proportionality sorts of our units is because these two numbers
the range on earth and the range on this unknown planet how far we can throw these rocks.
So we also know the ratio and ratios are used whenever we have
this proportionality sorts of our units.
What we already shown from the previous problem that the optimal range occurs at 45°
So if we can set at an initial velocity of this zero--these are the horizontal and vertical components.
Well, when we're calculating range the first thing we want to know is
how much time does the object spent in the air.
And we think of measuring to the top of the trajectory and then multiplying by two.
Have we find the time it takes to get to the top?
What we used is equation, we plugged in our known values and solve for t.
And I noticed I have been using numbers, I have been keeping
everything in terms of variables except for this 45°.
This could be an intimidating tactic to use when you're first solving physics problems.
Often you tend to want to plug everything in, but actually you could often get more interesting results
if you leave the variables in place and don't plug until the very, very end.
Anyways, this is the time to the top of the trajectory but we know
the full time is twice that so I'll just put a 2 here.
Once we know the time, how do we find the range?
We'll we used this equation and now I've plugged in for the initial velocity
the initial x velocity V₀ cosine of 45.
I've multiplied by the time that we just calculated because remember
in the x direction the acceleration is always zero.
Okay, let's simplify--well, I've multiplied the V₀ together to get this V₀² and actually
if I carry out cosine of 45 times 945, I find it's just equal to one half.
This part the one half cancelled with the 2, I've find that my
maximum range is equal to my initial V²/a.
Now, I do not really care about V₀².
I want to know how range scales with a and it turns out well it's
proportional to 1/a or R is proportional to a⁻¹.
Well so what, how do I use that--just like we did early in the unit, we found out using a lot of ratio
and the ratio of the range on earth to the range of this unknown planet is going to be equal
to the ratios of the accelerations taken to the -1 power.
A -1 power just means flip what you have inside.
I can solve this for the unknown acceleration and I get this equation.
The acceleration on our unknown planet is equal to the ratios of
the ranges times the acceleration on earth.
When I found what we know, I find that the acceleration on our unknown planet must be
1.6 m/s², which is exactly the acceleration on the moon and we've figured out where we are.
Amazing work--there were other ways to solve this--equally valid--
but this is one tool that you should try to familiarize yourself with.